I think I have a missionary zeal
to bring culture closer to young people.
Being exposed to culture:  theater,
novels, films,  makes us better thinkers
and helps us understand
the problems of our world.
My name is Fatima Naqvi and I'm
a professor of German and film studies.
I am interested in the way we move in  built space
and how that built space influences us.
And my new project is on hospitals.
I started becoming interested in hospitals
as they were being built in the 1880s
in the Austro-Hungarian Empire.
And at that time, Austria-Hungary
was the epicenter of modern medicine.
They're thinking about every aspect:
ventilation, what kind of windows,
what kind of paint do you use on the walls,
wheras the late 20th century is very much
about all the stuff that's underground,
the hallways that are endless,
the bureaucracy that has to be navigated.
I was very interested in looking at
the way in which artists reflected on
those architectural advances.
I start with people like Arthur Schnitzler
and Rainer Maria Rilke.
I move through the 20th century via
authors like Thomas Bernhard
and then I actually look at filmmakers
in the 21st century
who work on this interface
of documentary and fiction.
There's a fantastic documentary
by Nikolaus Geyrhalter
about one of these large hospitals
that has been recently built in Vienna.
He starts us off in the basement
where these robots are transporting
dirty laundry and the refuse
that's left over at the end of the day.
Watching this film,
you realize that there's so much of it
that happens behind closed doors
and underground,
this whole machine hospital complex
to which we're not really privy, but which determines
our experience once we're in those walls.
It shows us a world
where there's no daylight,
and it leads also to reflect upon
what it might mean
for health and recovery
to be in these
completely artificial spaces.
A lot of films started to deal with this
in light of Europe's aging population.
And we saw it with the pandemic.
We were bombarded
with images of people in ICUs.
These last few years have shown us
how hospitals
are a very fraught topic for us.
What does it mean for the end of our lives
that we spend these
in institutional settings where we are
very cut off from the outside?
Most of my work arises
out of conversations with people.
The wonderful thing
about Yale is that the colleagues are so willing
to listen to each other,
throw ideas around, to be very open
and very curious.
And the Yale School of Architecture
is here.
People there have helped me
think about space in a new way.
As I then encounter particular works of art, books
that I'm reading, films that I'm viewing, some of them
start to speak in a new way then,
and I want to dig deeper.
And that usually does entail going
to the archives, looking at manuscripts, storyboards,
to see what kind of notes
are there in the margins,
what things tell us beyond the printed page
or the completed project.
I am hoping to make people more aware
of their material surroundings,
to think more profoundly about what kind of spaces
we are creating for ourselves,
for our children, for the future.
Whether you're looking at a building
or a film or
a billboard,
everything around us in human culture
can be read and interpreted.
And I think that we have to return to them
over and over again
to be able to finally really see them
and understand them.
That's not something that you
can do with a quick glance.